welcome back the business secretary told
Sky News this week that many thousands
of jobs would go if Britain leaves the
EU without a deal many of those jobs
could be from small businesses and the
chairman of the Federation of small
businesses Mike cherry is here in the
studio mr. cherry very good to see you
again and just how bad is it for your
members at the moment oh clearly at the
moment if we just crashed out with no
deal there will be disaster for many
small business it's simple reason they
don't have the resource to plan for
something they don't know what they're
having to plan for and you only have to
take this into the context where we are
at the moment with the domestic issues
you have confidence at the lowest it's
been for considerable amount of time
with the fourth quarter index from FSB
very clearly showing it in negative
territory again you have got cost
increases and at the moment business
just doesn't know what it's got to plan
for so how can it plan when you say that
they don't know what to plan for surely
there can't be a business up there
anywhere in the United Kingdom right
though that doesn't actively consider
nor deal to be a very real possibility
certainly a lot more a lot more of a
realistic outcome than it was six months
ago
indeed but if you look back at March
many businesses who were able to plan
that was about one in seven
spent a lot of money a lot of time
either in inventory or in establishing
offices overseas in Brussels in
Amsterdam or in Dublin and of course
that never actually materialized what we
don't want is to go through the same
scenario again at the end of October and
again have a delay on that we need to
know what we've got to plan for we need
to be able to put contingency plans in
place if we have to and we need to just
get on with this and presumably part of
that would be some form of financial
assistance coming from government at
least on that you are hearing from both
the candidates that could be the next
prime minister that there will be money
available to organizations small
businesses I would certainly hope
there's something available but until we
know what is actually going to happen
you can't even say that you need money
to be available business just wants to
know what it has to do and if it isn't
No Deal scenario we need government to
actually make sure that it is ready
itself and to be able to inform business
what it has to do to comply whether it
be tar
whether it be customs clearance or other
issues so has there been anything that's
grabbed you I mean obviously you will
have been paying close attention as
indeed all your members to the hustings
and the debates and newspaper articles
about the next conservative leader I
mean of the - who do you prefer we don't
choose sides I think one of the crucial
things that people have to remember is
that our membership was absolutely split
no different to the general population
booth almost straight down the middle so
we've been concentrating very much on as
free and open access to trade with the
european union's as much as possible we
need the right people with the right
skills and of course we then need to
expand for those businesses that are
looking to do overseas trade
particularly with the US Canada
Australia New Zealand China and other
emerging but even within but even within
that the FSB itself there is a sizeable
chunk not quite half but a sizeable
chunk of your membership that is
remarkably sanguine about an audio isn't
there is but that applies on both sides
so we've been very very focused indeed
through repeated surveys of our
membership on what it is that the
businesses need to do what they want to
do to ensure that whether it be a
service sector business being able to
get their people across into other
countries as freely as possible whether
it be trade and even if you had some
increases in types that would prove
hugely detrimental to many many
businesses who are trading with the EU
okay so what happens then what happens
on November the first to give of the
organizations that you represent if we
leave without you
well it was interesting only the other
week I was over in Northern Ireland and
you had the example there that a
business that currently have all that
piss labels ready to trade within the EU
if there was a crash out on the 1st of
November all of that labeling all of
that produce in stock would actually
have to be changed if they wanted to
deal with the EU and separately within
the UK and that is a massive thing for
any small business to have to try and
contend with it's often said I just want
you to go a bit of context you know that
small businesses are the backbone of the
British economy I mean
who is that today that is very very true
indeed because if you look at how many
are actually engaged within a supply
chain of one type or another it's around
about 70 percent so even though you've
only got perhaps 20 percent exporting it
is a considerable number that are likely
to be affected were there to be a crash
out with no deals so we're very very
focused on Parliament coming together
making sure that we have a transition
period and making sure that we have a
deal so there's only one change the
businesses have to contend with I come
back to the point that I made in the
beginning there cannot be a businessman
in this country that does not recognize
then your dealers are very it's reality
know that it is an outcome that could
well compare come to fruition on top of
that the you know the statistic that we
talked about previously not just less
than half of your members you know kind
of quite happy with your deal who hasn't
been preparing for an ordeal but let's
just come back to the point that I made
the earlier end of March we had the
possibility of no deal end of October we
have the reality of a possibility again
of no deal but it's a domestic issue
that our members are much more focused
on moment increases in costs you've got
six year year-on-year
cost increases on national living wage
for those sectors that are having to pay
those sorts of wages you have auto
enrolment increasing you have business
rates which is not just on retail all of
these are coming at a perfect time to
create that storm that business is being
faced with and it's the domestic issues
that are of more concern even now as we
approach new government new prime
minister possibility of crashing out at
the end of October yes always a bumpy
time anyway isn't it at Mike cherry that
would you see in fact join us